liberty baptist theological seminary
which was founded by jerry falwell
he told us that he has
six guns under his bed waiting for
muslims uh to come over hallelujah
islam is reality
god is reality hey lou i hear some
muslims saying allahu akbar would you
like me to come with my shotgun and then
took me a couple of times on different
uh evangelistic trips he made by by
plane so a person that hated completely
islam now wanted to learn how to become
a muslim pearl mcintyre i used to fly
with him a lot when i was a student at
shelton college right he pointed like
this and it was very scary for us never
be afraid
to trust
an unknown future
to a known god the deed the the show
[Music]
to the dean shaw media host and we have
some exciting guests in the dean show
studio
former pastor and also someone who looks
like jesus that's right here on a dean
show when we come back don't go anywhere
go ahead and subscribe right now hit
that notification bell help us get our
numbers back up did you know that
many years ago the dean show when we
started 2006 we used to broadcast for
many years on the khalifa clothing
channel currently known as digital
minbot so we're trying to get our
numbers back up because the channel at
that time got closed then we started the
official d show channel we're trying to
get our numbers back up to where they
should be
and that's this number here 855 combined
what we currently have 442 we should be
over a million 200
000 subscribers help us to get our
numbers back to where they should be
with that small setback that we had many
years ago you guys can help us by
subscribing right now and hitting that
notification bell thank you very much
enjoy the rest of the show
and don't forget to support us on our
patreon page assalamu alaikum how are
you guys doing
samuel
did i introduce it right former pastor
that's correct and you also studied at
the bible university called well
faith theological seminary and then
liberty baptist theological seminary
which was founded by jerry falwell yes
and
this is isaac
they call him jesus jesus because
technically isa translated into english
means jesus right that's correct now on
your way something very interesting
happened on your way here you guys you
got delayed because of a helicopter
helicopter crashed right by our hotel we
couldn't
it's you know traffic was stacked up
trying to get down the road it's not
every day you get to see a helicopter
crash is it not at all i mean we crashed
right in the street next to our hotel
the last one that came to mind that i
remember it was a very very famous
basketball player i know if you remember
bryant kobe bryant you remember that yes
so i did a program on that i did
something well actually a reminder just
reminding people because again you would
think that i mean you know that kobe
bryant probably had the best
pilot
gases in the tank
all the mechanicals
are up to line but you just never know
right like this person today who crashed
you just never know it's a reminder for
all of us it'll be on the news tonight
yeah you guys sent me a picture
hopefully we get that up people can
actually see it
um so
yeah that's and that's one of the things
like just doing the program that's one
of the the main messages connected with
getting out there to the people the
purpose of life and one of those
connecting point is to prepare for the
afterlife
yeah you never know
you never know when it's time to go it
could be it can be a plane crash
helicopter crash it can be
covet it could be could actually
actually be a car crash
yeah you just or a heart attack anything
there's so many means to the yeah it
means to the end yeah
so how would last time we went a little
more in depth of your history
you were studying to let's just kind of
uh for the people that didn't watch that
so they can kind of get familiar
in a condensed version of your story
to actually going from studying in
seminary school theological school
about
a christian pastor to here on the dean
show with us
okay well you know i was born in
charleston south carolina my dad was a
navy pilot
and he was involved in a plane crash
and he survived that plane crash by six
months the third month he was in the
hospital i was born
then he died three months later so i
never knew him
but my mother moved to north georgia
in georgia she took me to first baptist
church
and in the church was a library
and she would take me every sunday after
the service to the library i was able to
pick out a children's book and i'd take
it home with me and she would read it to
me the book i got many times was called
the god of abraham and my mother would
say to me sami sami sami you have to pay
attention you have to pray to the god of
abraham don't forget that
there's only one god
i was taught that by a christian mother
i think about a hundred million
americans were taught that when they
were children either in vacation bible
school
sunday school
but they were taught to pray to the god
of abraham there's only one god but they
don't know what is islam
so we're trying to find that 100 million
there was your brother had heard an
interesting story can you share that
story with us isa yeah so uh we met him
lou shropshire uh just three years ago
and so when we went into um his uh when
we were going there samuel told us that
he has six guns under his bed waiting
for muslims to come over
and so
we went there and we spoke to him about
different topics but we didn't get to
speak to him too much about islam it was
indirect tawa and so it was time for
prayer and so he said yeah it is time
for prayer we said yes we can pray later
but he said no you can go ahead right
now i would like to take a video of it
so as we went inside to make
we saw a poster and it said to kill a
muslim and to take him directly to hell
you put um what's it called the bullet
in pig grease and so we were like wow
we're very surprised um but then we made
with we started praying and when we pray
we say allahu akbar allahu akbar and is
that like a war cry no that's what
people think
sadly
god is great that's it
is it kind of like a hallelujah yeah it
is yeah it is i mean alhamdulillah god
is great god is wonderful hallelujah no
hallelujah you should be happy
okay so you were saying like yeah
equivalent to hallelujah god is the
greatest correct and then what happened
and so um his neighbor heard us and so
he said hey lou i hear some muslims
saying allahu akbar would you like me to
come with my shotgun and then lu
shropshire said not yet i will let you
know
so there is still a possibility and then
he told us to sleep over his house i was
like maybe he didn't catch us the first
time while praying now he wants to catch
us while sleeping and so we slept we
woke up alhamdulillah we were about to
leave but he started us
still asking us some questions and then
two questions he asked us and he said
how can i come to islam how can i be a
muslim and so a person that hated
completely islam now wanted to learn how
to become a muslim and so we told him
the six pillars of faith we told him
i bear witness that there is no god
except allah and prophet muhammad is a
messenger and so he said i believe in
allah and i believe in the prophet
muhammad peace be upon him and he said
he will learn more in the future but the
second thing that affected me he said
you know it's not my fault that i don't
know about islam it's your fault that
you never told me about islam or any
muslim told me about islam he lived for
more than 80 years and nobody told him
about islam but alhamdulillah we reached
out to him before his death two years
before his death and a couple of months
ago we went to his memorial and saw him
uh there now there are can you imagine
how many people are out there just like
that correct they have the wrong
perception about islam
much of it through the media and much of
it sometimes to just fringe elements
uh not representing islam correctly and
then you have also sometimes deliberate
attempts to divide us as human beings by
certain corrupt people organizations
whoever the case because the big
industry now making money fueling this
division
yes this hate of islam because you'll
always be fearful of the unknown you'll
be fearful
of the unknown but now you're this is
your brother he gets the proper
education he just spends a little bit of
time asking questions look how powerful
that was that at the end then he saw you
guys praying coincidentally like jesus
prayed with your face on the ground
that's how jesus prayed and practicing
the same way of life that jesus
practiced is nothing different
submitting your will because islam means
to submit your will to the creator of
the heavens and earth and that's what
you guys were doing to the point that
he's like how can i what did he say how
can i be a muslim and that sign he had a
sign so you imagine the kind of
distorted you know ideas that a person
had and the hatred that he had assigned
this is how you send them to
hell put a bullet in the pigs
grease yes
man it's bad but you know it's not his
fault and i like this it's partially our
so now he's pointing yes and then he put
the camera yes yes right he pointed like
this and it was very scary for us
because he said you know it's not my
fault that i didn't know about islam
it's your fault that you never told me
about islam or any muslim never told him
about islam so for the 80 years that he
lived no one told him about islam and
like him there's hundreds of millions of
people dying every year not knowing
anything about islam and so if we can
reach out to them many of them like
brother samuel would come into islam
what did you think after this encounter
with your brother now and all this you
know
his reaction
well you know
you think of reality reality is
islam is reality
god is reality alhamdulillah
and
the reality is
he loves us he cares for us he has mercy
upon us
the more i learned about islam and the
more i learned about prophet muhammad
peace be upon him
the more i understood
god's grace and mercy
god the most merciful the god who
distributes mercy to all who request
freely
alhamdulillah
it's a great experience
and now to be able to share that mercy
with others and to be able to share that
salvation with others who are seeking
help
so you went from one point in our last
interview you were talking to us about
how you were with uh jerry farwell
senior
and you were in the uh playing with him
right you guys are traveling his plane
no no yeah yeah he took me a couple of
times on different
uh evangelistic trips he made by by
plane
and i got to see him in action
and it was a
you know there were many good things
about thomas road baptist church but he
was like the at that time was he the top
evangelical
yeah would you say tv evangelist tv
evangelist you know the top yeah who is
there any others that you've had
encounter with or that you were friends
with or
carl mcintyre i used to fly with him a
lot when i was a student at shelton
college what was his name carl mcintyre
is he still alive no he passed away
about 20 years ago yeah but he was a
fundamentalist presbyterian preacher a
friend of ian paisley from northern
ireland ian paisley was a member of the
british parliament i used to wait on
i will i would work sometimes in the
dining room at shelton college ian
paisley would come and speak
he was a member of the british
parliament from northern ireland and he
was
just
firing brimstone preacher
he
preached hatred against catholics
but eventually before he died ian
paisley totally changed
he was man who uh
repented
he went to his enemies sinn fein in
northern ireland and they made friends
and then they were able to put the
country back together again
where chin feign and paisley working
together
we
need more leaders
who will take a stand taking a stand is
okay
brother eddie
taking a stand for righteousness is okay
but you don't
take a stand against truth
and when you don't take a stand without
against islam without examining it
my goodness
you know the top four
islam preaching
people of germany and and
and
the netherlands have all converted to
islam
in the most within the last few years
they've come to faith
and they are now preaching
islam around the world
and again just for our audience i mean
that concept of submitting your will to
the creator to heavens and earth has
always been there now it's encapsulated
with one word islam to submit to acquire
peace by submitting yourself entirely to
the owner of peace to creator to heavens
and earth jesus did it moses did it your
mother taught you about abraham the pure
monotheist there was no christianity or
judaism back then it was just pure tohit
the pure monotheism and that's the way
we're upon the way of abraham and all
the prophets and messengers and muhammad
just being the last to find a messenger
sentiment
it just makes sense you know and it
makes sense that now a person would want
to know their creator what the purpose
of life is you're living it now and so
many people down south that southern
hospitality as we call it there's so
much i often see they have so many of
the family values the moral values we
have so much in common
we need people like yourself and others
to connect you know like with your
brother and i feel they will gravitate
so much and at the end of the day even
if they choose not to accept itself no
part we make a friendship that if we
have people who are uh better to have
abu talibs than abu jahls right exactly
because allah is the one god almighty is
the one that guys
yeah so this is a very important thing
yes this is what
go ahead this is what we're trying to
reach with muslim voice for peace and
reconciliation our international
organization trying to reach out with
these people inshallah to bring them
closer to allah subhanahu ta'ala because
many of them will come to islam if they
really just know the truth about islam
so it's upon us to reach out to these
people and talk to them about islam and
they will insha allah most likely accept
islam or be like abu talib at least with
the muslims for people that know abu
talib he wasn't muslim but he supported
the muslims he defended right correct
and this is at the end of the day better
than having abu jahl
i want your reaction to this every
church had a bible like this you know
every christian family had a a bible
like this and they put their
their family to technology weddings
baptism baptisms and burials it was all
put inside the bible and you passed it
down generation generation this
particular bible
was published in in 1905.
now the reason i brought it out is that
i i want to show
a map that's in this bible now my do
the scofield bible was not published
until 1913 right and i have in my office
an original 1913 scofield
which was the introduction of the
zionist masonic
heresies
about
a future state of israel and separating
the church from israel and all that
rapture stuff that's where it came from
it was a masonic
zionist heresy that was introduced into
the american churches in 1913. this is
in 1905
bible pre school preschool filled with
no scofield notes in it
so
you open it up
and uh this is on page 13. i mean this
thing's big uh i want to show you here
is
here is a map
of the holy land
and it says
what
oh
palestine well that's the holy land they
misspelled israel no palestine palestine
huh and all these christian zionists to
tell me rick there's never been a
palestine all right so here's a still
there it is let's zoom in and show you
here yeah
so yeah you hear these people like john
hagee there's never been a palestine
well look at this bible map from 1905
and most
in most bibles yes from then had a map
of palestine palestine and palestine is
in
the bible itself
in the old testament
so
we're showing you this just because
your reaction
he's absolutely true
absolutely right
all you have to do is look at
coins and money and history you see
palestine everywhere
how much do you know about this uh you
know you've heard the scofield bible
that he's talking about yeah yeah yeah i
was raised on school you were raised on
the school field bible yeah wow so it
seemed like what he's saying is
there was much of the propaganda pushed
through here the reason i'm bringing
this up is because
how much do you know about this rapture
because this is that form this
connection and now the muslims are the
enemy because of all this yeah
um well
we were raised believing in the rapture
uh we were raised believing in
not just
pre
pre-millennial
theology
that
that jesus would return before the
millennium but even more than that we
were
pre-when we talk about the rapture
there are several points of view
it's either pre-tribulation
mid-tribulation or post-tribulation
now the tribulation period was before
the rap i was at the time before jesus
establishes a thousand years of peace on
earth
and that was called
the
you know it was said that christians
were going to raise from the dead
that we would join with christ
in the air
so we used to always have a greeting
here there or in the air here there in
the air yeah
that's the rapture greeting yeah okay
god
given us more knowledge now
and i thank god for islam i thank god
for the quran
and i thank god for the hadith that also
give us information about the future yes
but it's certainly more accurate than
what we're getting through scofield
reference bible which was indeed a
propaganda tool for
the creation of the state of israel so
what uh rick here from true news what
they are talking about he's
on point yes he is yeah and it seems
like he's actually
if more people knew about this
i believe there'll be less hatred
against muslims in islam that's true
so this is this is very important
information here would you say very
important yeah uh so let me tell you so
is it also true from the from the
rapture this seems like it's called what
we call the bidder
you know innovation like this is
something that was just
innovated and now many christians they
fell for this like you said the
propaganda
uh whoever set it up and now this
created a big rift between
christians and muslims
who follow this methodology the apostle
paul in in his writings uh spoke quite a
bit about the rapture
uh he said that
christ would return
that there will be a trumpet sound
that the dead in christ shall rise first
then they which are alive will be caught
up together with them in the clouds and
so shall they ever be with the lord
that's from thessalonians
uh the apostle paul
has been discredited in a lot of his
writings
as it
as we've examined
but we have good news at him about
palestine samuel and i've been there two
years ago alhamdulillah
we were introduced to many leaders over
there we went to ten different cities
alhamdulillah we spoke in different
mosques alhamdulillah they even
alhamdulillah gave us permission to give
a talk in al-aqsa mosque alhamdulillah
and so that was an opportunity and we
also distributed pamphlets on via de la
rosa which is two hundred feet away from
us alhamdulillah
dela rosa is a street where many
christians believe
that christ carried his cross on the way
to calvary and masha'allah now hundreds
of jews alhamdulillah are coming to
islam
through alhamdulillah in palestine and
so this is great news alhamdulillah and
this is why we're establishing an
exhibition there insha'allah to explain
to people to these people more about
islam because sadly there's many
different exhibitions and museums for
our christians many many religious
terrorist yeah there's five million
religious tourists go there every year
to palestine and so they don't know
about islam because there isn't many a
good exhibition or museum talking to
them about slabs so we're building the
first one insha'allah we're already
about the building now we're renovating
the inside insha'allah uh just to go
back a little bit more on this rapture
um because
if we can clear some of this up you know
like this christian
i believe is he a pastor is he uh um i i
don't know him um if this christian now
who's also getting he was talking about
peggy hagie yes no is did you ever know
he's an evangelical pastor in texas is
he still around yeah he's still around
preaching hard
but have you ever met him i've never met
him okay
i met a lot of them but i haven't met
him yeah he's very famous he's quite
well known amongst evangelical
christians does he preach that um
hate towards islam and muslims or what's
he well
yes he does he does he says
anyone who's against israel
god is against them
that's his word uh if that's the case
then anyone who wants to reclaim the
homeland for the palestinians is against
god and that simply is not the case
so then is another part of that belief
okay
is that
when jesus comes back who we believe is
going to come back we believe in the
return of jesus yes we can touch upon
that but they believe that now
uh the
the jews will either convert or die how
does that work right
well uh they're certainly doing a lot of
evangelistic work amongst the jews
uh they believe that 144 000 according
to the book of revelation
by the apostle john
that uh
000 will convert
during the time of the tribulation
during the rule of the antichrist and
they will all uh disappear
so the inference is that they're going
to be killed that's the
that's what it's alluding to yes okay so
does that form that connection then that
that is that what's forming this you
know this connection uh of some kind of
um alliance here that they're so
connected because okay the end result is
they're going to be
christians
they'll be christians
144 000 that specific number so how do
you reconcile from what he's saying to
what this one which one is obviously
more authentic so now the christian
who's watching this who's been you know
thinking okay the
muslims are enemies you know what i mean
dip them the bullets in the blood and
all this crazy stuff you know what i
mean like how can they get to the truth
so they can end up you know getting past
this like which one so he's saying one
thing this one which one is the more
authentic i would say to the christians
what would you say
read the quran there you go read the
quran
you have nothing to lose
read the quran and you'll read about
maryam you'll read about asa you'll read
in the quran that asa jesus
is the christ and the messiah of god
that jesus did many miracles including
raising the dead back to life again
you'll read about jesus
there are two miracles in the koran that
are mentioned that are not mentioned in
the bible that he did
you'll read about jesus who was born of
the virgin mary
jesus who ascended to god in heaven and
jesus who's soon coming again
i like i love the answer you gave
because over here it's a lot it's
confusion upon confusion but you just
ended that confusion read the quran the
last and final revelation sent to
mankind tamper-free temper proof
you have everything in there you name
the chapter named after
jesus's blessed mother it's in the quran
i had one christian that we did a
program his name was owen and he was a
staunch
opponent of islam he was actually
writing songs for the former tommy
robbins whatever his name is edl you
know writing songs for him you know he
was a script writer for lauder for
crowder he was also someone who was just
saying some very disturbing things
against prophet muhammed peace and
blessed be upon him now he says prophet
muhammad peace be upon him and one key
thing that i remember he said he said
when he started looking further into
this he said hold on
certain people over here they insult
jesus
the muslims over here when they say
jesus say peace be upon him they hold
him to the highest respect and reverence
blessings blessings and
now
they also
praise his mother while others say some
of the most disturbing things this
doesn't make sense hold on and he had an
awakening and he had so many of his
followers at the same time when after
they saw me and him talk they said how
can we be such fools that we were for 20
years i was like having this impression
about islam but after i saw you two
talking so many of them were making
these comments after that they said wow
they re-evaluated everything and said
man because people it's like they took
that red pill you know they called it
the red pill and they had an awakening
so now people are saying you former
former pastor you know
at the seminary theological schools
teaching preaching smuggling bibles into
different countries and now you're
telling people read the quran
what kind of impact do you have when you
stand in front of people who have this
type of mindset that we just talked
about that we're trying to get people
out of well you know i went to
fundamentalist christian schools
bob jones academy christian high school
to boarding school i went to shelton
college fundamentalist presbyterian
faith theological seminary
fundamentalist presbyterian liberty
baptist theological seminary
fundamentalist baptist and then
california graduate school of theology
in glendale california that's why i was
ordained by the united community church
to serve as a pastor not a pastor of a
church
but a pastor in non-profit
leadership
working in human rights
so i'm very grateful to god for the
direction he's given me in life
but i would have never never in my life
imagined that i would be sitting in
saudi arabia today
near mecca in mecca quite often asa and
i go to mecca and pray
we
uh we're doing umrah there we're doing
i've done
uh
hajj
i've done hajj and the bible is called
becca right becca the valley of becca
and the psalms
and um
i'm i'm just so grateful
who could have imagined
when i was running to be mayor of
annapolis because i'd gotten involved in
politics running for mayor of annapolis
uh if if god if someone had told me then
you're not going to be mayor
you're going to be a muslim sitting in
saudi arabia you're going to be living
in a mosque
you're going to be
having doing hajj
you're going to
be praying five times a day
and you're going to have a son named
jesus
i look at him he's my son
if i ever had a real son i would want
him to be exactly like
like jesus here
god has so blessed me
and so encouraged me in life
so the story behind that real quickly is
your father
he actually you have what four other
brothers five five five older brothers
and your father and he signed over the
paperwork no jokingly
he said jesus as a sacrifice
i was having dinner with their home one
night
i was very much interested in protecting
the environment i called it creation
care
and i met dr mohammad alhaj hussein
who's the head of the green building
council for saudi arabia
he invited me to his home for dinner
when i got there at five sons sitting at
the table until we had a six son
studying for a phd in edinburgh scotland
and i said allah dr muhammad six sons
no daughters six sons
he said yes i said i've only got one
child i have a beautiful daughter her
name is jenna i love her very much
but i've never had a son i've always
wanted a son you've got six give me one
of yours
he said take jesus
and then this is when we started
together
the organization muslim voice for peace
and reconciliation
tell me um
this is amazing because any person who
is god fearing god loving conscious of
god the creator when you look into
the bible and i just mentioned okay you
mentioned hajj mecca it's in there becca
the first house of worship built by
abraham to commemorate the worship of
the one and only one god fasting the way
muslims fast it's in the bible right
praying the way we pray jesus didn't
pray like this right he's
humbled himself put his forehead on the
ground this is the way we pray
circumcision i mean everything you don't
have to connect the dots too much to see
like this is islam it's there islam in
the bible so many people like yourself
have interviewed so many people who've
done the same thing they were looking
for the truth and they say the bible
actually led me to islam so what does
somebody now watching a christian pastor
preacher uh scholar what do you like to
tell them okay one thing is read the
quran i usually tell people look
earnestly within yourself don't put a
middle man between you and the creator
ask for guidance directly from the one
who created you the same god that jesus
worship call upon him alone i mean i
mean
all i can say is my great love for jesus
the christ and the messiah of god
led me to islam
some people say heresy heresy there's no
heresy in that
every now and then i run into a
christian friend that i knew years
earlier and they'll say come back to
jesus come back to jesus
this happened once in palestine at a
presbyterian church
and i told the pastor
i said pastor george i've never left
jesus
i love jesus to christ and the messiah
of god the virgin born jesus i love him
more today than i ever have before in my
life
and
the pastor he began to
shake his head and
he went into his office for a while
and he came out i i was there when he
came out of came back out of his office
he was crying
i said what's wrong pastor george you're
upset with me he said no i saw your
website i said you're upset
no
he said i've never seen a muslim who
loves
i've never seen a muslim who loves
christians as much as you do
i said yes well i said you haven't met a
lot of muslims then because we do love
christians christians are closest to
islam
and we want them to understand properly
what is islam
yeah tell him about the church when you
spoke in a church
in christmas
oh yeah it was a catholic church in
annapolis maryland saint mary's catholic
church
they asked me to come and speak to a
group of the leaders in the church
and at first i was thinking no i don't
think i want to do that
because
but then i thought no i will
i went i sat in front of them
and i read from the koran
about the virgin birth of jesus
and the priest raises his hand he says
just a minute where are you reading in
the bible which gospel are you reading
they thought you're reading the bible
when you're actually reading the quran
reading quran because i was reading
about
his the angel coming to mary and saying
you're going to have a child
and that
mary would be
the most highly exalted woman in the
world
he says which gospel are you reading so
i'm not reading from the gospel i'm
reading from
i'm reading from the quran
and he's
the priest began to cry
he says where can i get a copy of this
and i went out he followed me out to my
car afterwards several of the church
leaders and i was handing qurans out of
the back of my car
subhanallah
this is amazing this is the power
of the truth yes truth you know it's
it's and it's very simple it's not
something convoluted nebulous it's lucid
it's clear
worship like
your mother was teaching you you know
the god of abraham the one and only one
god not three in one one in three just
one god that's it and be morally upright
it's a simple message straightforward
and the proof is there it's clear jesus
at his time go ahead yeah we we speak
with christian and jewish groups quite
often
sometimes as many as 150 people in one
group
and
they want to know about islam
from my perspective because
they know that i recently
recognized the fact that i was muslim
so what i do is i project on the back
wall behind me
the fi the six pillars of faith
and i asked them how many of you here
today believe there's only one god
and all of them christians and jews
raised their hand
how many of you who are here today
believe in angels all hands go up
how many of you believe
in holy books
let's say like torah or angel or
or the gospels or the new testament old
testament everybody raises their hand
how many of you believe in prophets
these are men that god sent to earth at
specific times in history to specific
groups of people with his word
all hands go up
i said wow you're christians and jews
you believe those four things
what about
do you believe there's going to be a
time when we'll all stand before god
he's going to judge us for all the good
and bad things we've done on this earth
all hands go up
and then i ask them
how many of you believe that if god says
something's going to happen it's going
to happen
all hands go up
alhamdulillah
and then i tell them these are the six
pillars of faith in islam
you can't be a muslim this unless you
believe these six things those articles
of faith those articles of faith right
so
they're surprised
they're surprised that they believe the
same thing to muslims believe they
agreed all of it they agreed to all of
it then we get into discussion of the
five pillars of islam
uh the
statement of faith
and uh other points i call i call that a
call to action it's a proof it's called
action you gotta prove it now lip
service is cheap i love you but come on
do something about it you gotta go ahead
and and this is the five pillars put it
into action
yeah
so uh before we conclude uh just one
more thing it was just tickling me i was
thinking about this uh i remember the
former president and he had an advisor
this lady and she kept like talking in
his tongues right
did you ever participate in that i saw
this um
i saw a video of this you saw it she's
walking back and forth holding the bible
and
speaking in tongues um i've i've been
with people who've done that i used to
tell us a little bit about that i used
to attend a
christian church at charismatic church
where people were speaking in tongues
and
sometimes they get carried away
they even start barking like dogs
and they say these but this barking is
from the holy spirit
i've been there when it happened
or the pastor stands in front of the
congregation he says i see the holy
spirit
moving like a wave across the people and
as he points his finger across the crowd
they began to speak in tongues and bark
and yell
this has nothing to do with god
it has to do with
human emotion
and we need to come down to reality
there is some mention in the new
testament in the
writings of the apostle paul about
speaking in tongues
but it doesn't
command that we speak in tongues
they say these tongues are
one foreign languages that the disciples
you know when they were gathered at
pentecost they used they began speaking
in foreign languages and these foreign
languages were recognized by people in
jerusalem so they saw it as a miracle
but they weren't speaking in unknown
tongues
and what about the uh i believe it's in
the last part
is it a book of uh
brother has given me a deadly poison and
he wants me to drink it that
it is true what is written in mark 16
that if we drink something that is
poisoned we will not die the playing
with snakes drinking of the poison
or
first john i think it's 5 7 where it
talks about father son and holy spirit
these verses are missing from the
original
transcripts from the oldest manuscripts
of the bible of the new testament
they're not there
the one about handling snakes
all of these verses are not there the
one handling snakes that's at the end of
was that is that matthew
uh i'm sorry i can't remember yeah which
book it was in but so what's the purpose
of
have you seen also this some of the
handling of the snakes and then i heard
it less poison in west virginia it's
still going on in the country churches
pastors
walking around handling snakes trying to
prove that they're
that god's protecting them yeah
god doesn't expect us to do foolish
things to demonstrate his protection
do they know they must not know that
this is not in any original manuscripts
or anything it's not there it's not in
the oldest manuscripts not even the
original which we don't have but the
oldest extent manuscripts that we have
these verses are not there and when you
look at modern
translations of the greek
new testament these they omit these
verses did you know at that time that
when you were practicing christianity
i'm sure i had one um
grant him jenna dr gerald dirks he was a
he was a deacon ordained deacon he
finished from the
harvard university got his theology
degree and he was uh what they call a
doctor of divinity i believe and he when
he went to seminary school he saw you
know textual criticism he was seeing
like what passages were connected to
anything you know of some kind of
manuscript or whatnot and he said when
now he would watch people on the pulpit
preaching and teaching like you you
mentioned the verse that they connected
to the trinity for their three their
record in heaven the father the son and
the those but these three are one that's
not even there right
uh that was in addition
he couldn't do it he had integrity he
couldn't preach these
verses when he knows they're not there
yeah
and then he ended up accepting islam
actually he was truthful he was honest
with himself honest with god almighty
allah
so my question here is did you know at
that time at what time and do most of
these preachers and teachers know who
have more of an academic education that
there is not a copy of a copy of a copy
of a copy of any original original bible
original text that has been lost change
edited do they know that let me say that
when i went to bob jones academy
well at least when i began studying at
shelton college
people began to be more truthful about
textual criticism
we were told even at faith theological
seminary liberty baptist theological
seminary that there are verses
in the bible that are not in the oldest
manuscripts
um
so you know our eyes were open
we were taught
textual criticism
but
people began to deal with reality
reality is that there are many parts of
the new testament that are not factual
when i say many
maybe that's
a bit extreme
but there are
quite a few places in the new testament
where we know absolutely these verses
were not in the original or they're not
in the oldest manuscripts and today in
the new translations of the bible which
are very popular amongst evangelicals if
you look for those texts they're not
there most people have the common
impression that matthew wrote matthew
john john mark but that's not the case
these are anonymous books people of
course call the gospel books matthew
mark luke and john well they call it
matthew mark luke and john because we
don't know who wrote these books and
there's no point calling them sam fred
jerry and harry i mean they're they're
written by people we don't know who they
were written by they are anonymous you
might not think so because they have the
title the gospel according to matthew
whoever put that title on it was an
editor later the followers of jesus were
aramaic speaking peasants from galilee
lower class men
who were not educated
in fact peter and john in acts chapter 4
verse 13 are literally said to be
illiterate
they couldn't read and write of course
not they were fishermen they didn't go
to school the vast majority of people in
the ancient world never learned to read
let alone write and their native
language was aramaic these books are
written in greek
by highly educated rhetorically trained
writers who are skilled in greek
did you know that at that time no you
know in academic circles like bart aaron
bible scholars bart
they point out that matthew
mark luke and john
that these are anonymous books well they
call them matthew mark luke and john
because we don't know who wrote these
books and there's no point calling them
sam fred jerry and harry i attended a
course in
that that wasn't sure remember they were
talking about it the students of
um one of them they were training us in
this dawah course and they were telling
us the same thing yeah most people
if you can imagine i mean and again this
is not to leave someone
uh on a ship now and now they don't have
a destination i love what you said shay
um
you mentioned read the quran you do have
now
uh
final testament
you have it there final testament we
have the old testament new testament and
god's final testament yeah so god loves
us god wants to guide us he's the most
merciful loving you if you're tuning in
here this makes sense look into it some
more just like your brother it made
sense the way you guys were praying it
made sense what you were saying the
the simple message of the one and only
creator that happens on earth and
and then he wanted to learn more he
wanted to accept
this dean this way of life
tell us you guys went above and beyond
now you have this uh organization
in the last few minutes that we have
tell us about it and this is an
organization trying to go ahead and
deliver this message the message of
jesus abraham moses and the last and
final message
correct this is our job because the
prophets peace be upon them are not here
so we are here to spread uh islam and to
convey to people what islam is really
about this is what muslim voice for
peace and reconciliation is we started
this organization alhamdulillah six
years ago and our address is in
washington dc we've been to more than 50
countries alhamdulillah
around the world and more than 3 000
people have come to islam alhamdulillah
through this organization and through
our work alhamdulillah we have 20 in 20
countries we have national directors
branches or employees there
alhamdulillah working together for this
uh same purpose
and uh this is what our our vision
inshallah is to um it's a long vision
insha'allah it's to reach 1 billion
people and this is with the help of a
hundred thousand professionally trained
staff and volunteers insha'allah all
together working uh this best job allah
in the holy quran
chapter 31 verse 33 he says woman
who is better in speech than the one who
invites to allah so allah himself is
saying that there is no better person
than the one who invites to allah and
this is what we're trying to do inviting
people to the truth because many of them
don't know the truth and if they knew
the truth like brother samuel and like
others that muslim you've interviewed
would come to islam
if they really knew about the truth and
this is what we're trying to do
conveying the message alhamdulillah
we've been traveling right now for two
months non-stop alhamdulillah every day
a couple of meetings alhamdulillah and
we have a few different cities we're
going to after this in a few different
countries if you anyone would like to
know more insha'allah
they can go to um
mvpr.org muslim voice for peace and
reconciliation.org
they can learn more details inshallah
yeah caring and sharing yeah we're
trying sharing the truth education is
key sheikh tell us
samuel what now would you say for the
person tuning in
you got their attention they've been fed
a lot of lies a lot of misinformation
but they're listening right and it seems
like the fitra you know the nate
disposition is you know when we talk
about one and only one god it's it's
coming alive right uh what advice would
you give them they're up against the
world you know their family i spoke to
jason the other day and he was in a
military something similar i can go on
and on but he just experienced the
kindness of the muslims he read the
quran he's worried about what his wife's
going to say you know so many people out
there like that that what their neighbor
is going to say you know my community if
i'm a pastor i'm going to lose my
congregation
what do you say to them
never be afraid
to trust
an unknown future
to a known god
okay
i learned that in school wow but
never be afraid never be afraid to trust
an unknown future to a known god
the future is as great
as the promises of allah
and so we have a lot to look forward to
you know we could throw up our hands and
panic right now on these days of
pandemic
but we
we don't have to
we can trust in allah
but
also
trust in allah there are a lot of things
happening in the world today
even asap prophesied in the new
testament
the disciples asked him when what will
be the signs of your return
he said
or the signs of the end days he said
nation will rise against nation
kingdom
against kingdom
but the end is not yet it says men's
hearts failing them for fear think about
all these business owners right now in
the world their businesses are collapsed
can't trust god you're going to have a
heart attack
men's hearts failing them for fear
then it talks about diseases unknown
diseases appearing on the earth and one
will pop up after the other
god help us we're living in difficult
times i pray every day that god will
surround my wife and my daughter and my
friends with his angels
guardian angels it talks about this in
the quran
that
god is our hope and our salvation in
difficult days
listen with that never be afraid to
trust an unknown future with an
all-knowing god yeah this is beautiful
there you go jason and like people out
there who are nervous and scared of the
future
but god almighty knows best what's best
for you that's why he sent the quran he
sent the last final message prophet
muhammad peace and blessings be upon him
as a guidance
for all of mankind as a mercy
for all the worlds so thank you very
much again for being with us here on the
dean's show
and thank you guys for tuning in
and you can pick up a free copy of the
quran we should have it on the
dean's show website subscribe if you
haven't already and continue to tune in
we'll see you next time inshallah god
willing we started with peace we end
with peace peace we with you assalamu
alaikum